hey guys came here time for another
gained spot news update Nintendo is
reportedly bringing 50 unity games to EU
the Unity game engine is one of the most
popular development tools among indie
developers and Nintendo used GDC last
week as an opportunity to show off nine
unity titles running on the Wii U there
are also another 17 set for release
within the next two months and then we
have another 50 that are waiting in the
wings so we've got a lot of unity
content on the way said senior manager
of marketing diamond Baker speaking to
Siliconera the large number of unity
games heading to wii u is the result of
a deal nintendo and unity technologies
made back in 2012 the deal gave nintendo
the right to distribute the unity
development platform to its in-house
external and third party licensee
developers now that unity and Wii U is
finalized Nintendo has had discussions
and is definitely looking at adding
unity support to the Nintendo 3ds we've
got a lot of developers that want to
take advantage of it so we're working
towards that as well but nothing to
announce at this time then Tendo chose
to highlight the unity offering during
GDC in order to demonstrate to
developers how easy it is for them to
bring their creative ideas to Nintendo
systems said Steve singer vice president
of licensing and Nintendo of America so
the doll this promise of unity games
make the wii u a more alluring console
prospect what unity games have you
played in the past exactly how many
times did I say the word unity in this
video let me know in the comments box
below and for more wii u coverage why
not head on over to gain spot calm and
check out tomm McShea editorial on how
Nintendo plans to silently kill it
unity